Hello, welcome to Smartless. I'm Dan McBride and I've been a fan of this podcast for quite some time. From listening to it multiple times, I've decided there are a few things that we could do to improve this show. One, is fire the three fucking hosts and put me in instead. So I've done that. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. How's everybody doing? I've been seeing you guys in a long time. Bye. I feel like you last week. Oh, yeah, you saw me last week. No, but I'm like a week goes by. It's a long feels like a long time. I know. Sean, you woke me up this morning. You told me I'd be late for work.
That is true. That is also true. So we didn't return the text. But we went out to dinner and at the end, which was so embarrassing, we'll ordered to the wait staff that it was my birthday. That was embarrassing. Everybody in New York. And we at the end, they said, is it any, you know, any, I go, yeah, it's Sean's birthday. And so they brought out a piece of cake with kids. Yeah. So it's not as pretty a bed. It's so boring. It is an old trick that always works It's a fun one. Yeah speaking of birthdays We have an announcement of a really exciting new thing that we want to talk about
Wait, so and that exciting new thing Sean is is there new New podcast with Rex chat. It's called owned with Rex chat Oh good, I can't be chatting with him really briefly around at the end at the end normally when you you're like, I'm out of here. Fuck those guys. Stick around. Yeah. No. Save a little. Save a little bit for the dessert. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Hey, I don't know when this is going to air, but something can be tied into the presidential campaign as soon as you see our next guest. Okay. I mean, you just had an announcement yesterday on Twitter that didn't go well, but we're going to give all Ronny D a nice launch right now.
How did we get? I don't want to declare who my guest is before him, but how did we get? How did we get old Ivy League, Ron DeSantis in here. I love these guys who are all like, the elite and every single one of these guys are like double degrees from Ivy League colleges, Ted Cruz, the city. Right. All these guys are such clouds. Yeah.
Um, anybody else got anything else? Where's can we get to run? I got a couple things, but if you want to get, get out with it. No, go ahead. Let's hear your. I watch. I watch. I want to open stuff on his desktop right now.
I got. No, I wanted to say, what are the thing cold open ideas? No, let's hear it. We were, when Will and I were at dinner, I wanted to show him, was it weight theft still around the table? Oh, fuck. Ron, you're at the cold one, hey, Ron. Just get thirsty, Wade, we're right with you, Mr. D.
We were at dinner, and I said, I showed, I wanted to show Will something on Instagram. So he hit search. And when I hit search, all that came up were guys who were bears and dogs. Wait, what's the dog? Big guy. It's like a domesticated animal
that people have in their homes. I thought that was a description of a different type of like gay bears and dogs. And so it was if Jay it was unbelievable. And it was just all like big burly dudes and tight-chain shorts. We have just just thought I know that you still have an ass because if you touch one, like if you click on one thing, the algorithm thinks, oh, you must want to see everything is like, no, but you've been with Scotty a very cute bear for years.
17 years. Yeah. Okay. So why is there still a recent search for fucking hot bear? Wait a minute. Are you honestly asking me like you don't look at pictures of, I don't know, big, breasted, whatever. But he, no, I do not.
And I'm actually embarrassed to say that my, I have a non-existent relationship to porn. I'm, it's very odd. Well, the other one, the other one of the three, three, some is silent. So I do. I'm letting everybody else bury themselves in comments that will either cut or. Well, not a second. No, well, you're not clean on this at all. No, no, it's like, I don't either. I clicked like I clicked like one one time and then the algorithm sends you 10,000 things. So it's like I get 10,000. This is on Instagram. It's not porn. So this
is Instagram that he's looking at photographs. Oh, so it's like, God, it's like God it. So my photograph. So in letter. If the image is moving, then that's pornography. If it's still definitely different. But before you make me sound like I'm some kind of a monster will, don't wouldn't you agree that I'm not talking about porn and people's, you know, frequency. Yeah. Now, on my child's life, I can't remember the last time I looked at pornography. Can you say the same thing? I can.
I'm not a, I'm not a big porn guy. Right. But you're an average male who- I have never have been. It's something that's part of the male thing for some weird thing. I know. Yeah. But for some reason, that's just that, part of the male thing for some weird thing. I know. I know. But for some reason, that's just, that switch is just off.
But I hear the thing, I don't have a problem with people. Well, first of all, you have to be an adult. I think this is an important distinction that needs to be made. And I think that porn is really fucked with people's perception of what sex is. Sex is. It's 100%. Yeah, when kids are looking at it, but I looked at it when I was a kid and I didn't think that every sex session is like.
No, but it was different back then. Right. Just having this conversation because I've had this conversation with my kids and because with the older kids because they can find anything. Well, because the internet is so readily available and I'm not kidding when I say I sat them down and I said, guys, here's the deal. It's going to be, it's incredibly readily available. And I'm not kidding when I say, I sat them down and I said, guys, here's the deal. It's gonna be, it's, you might see me in one or two of them.
Right, yeah. As much as your mom and I, you know, monitor and look at what you guys look at online, which we do with, with a fair bit of frequency, we look at stuff, we have, part of the deal with them having devices is we get to look at messages, whenever we want and get to look at what they're looking at. And that's just, and it's just the way it is.
And so they know that. You get some of the good sites. Is that what you get? Yeah. And so, so I made sure to tell them that like, look, there's gonna be moments where we can't, there's nothing I can do about it. And you're gonna have access to this stuff.
And you need to know that it is not a good representation of what sex is, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, for all the pitfalls of. Right. And it was awkward. I mean, it was a tough conversation, but I felt like I had to do it. And of course, like any other human,
of course I've seen pornography. It's just not a porn's not a big part of my experience. It's just not my thing, but it's part of it. So we got it. There we go. No, not a big one part of it. Let's move on to Sanders. Okay, here we go. This guy, it's not really, it's not really Rondis and Dess. He's one of my favorite actors. He's one of my favorite writers. He's been in some of my favorite films and television shows, and some of them he even co-created or fully created himself.
Well. Doesn't live in Hollywood, so cool it on the coastal elite bonding session. Right. You're going to have to meet him where he is, fellas, which is right there at the top of Mount Fanny. He's the king of cool, the mayor of LaFland, and definitely the guy you most like to work with next. Are my intros the best? He's married to a Gia, and they've created an Ava and a Declan. Please welcome Georgia Zone, Mr. Daniel Richard McBride. Danny. It's me, Ron DeCentes. Hey, buddy.
Good luck. Oh, my God. What, what, what can did you pop? Was that a beer? It couldn't be further from a beer. It's a pineapple waterloo. Oh, boy. You could drink a beer because you're east coast right now, right?
So you have a lunch beer. Yeah, it's after 12. It's 12.43. So that's technically okay. That's that's within the realm of possibly. Yeah, yeah. And we're in North Carolina. I am in South Carolina. I'm in Charleston, South Carolina. Yeah, love me some Charleston.
I got to have some house out there in South Carolina. Look at that background. Nice depth down there. What is happening? Danny McBride. What's up, man? Thanks you all for having me on here. This is happening. Danny McBride. What's up, man? Thank you all for having me on here. This is incredible. Yeah. But I'm doing it. First of all, alien covenant. One of my favorites. Let's start there. Go ahead, Sean. I love it. I can't believe I, but I can't believe I've never met you. I'm a huge fan. That's some of my bad. I mean, he's not out here. He's, he's hiding in Charleston, keeping it all the Halloween movies that you wrote.
I like a massive, massive fan. Oh, thank you so much. That's hiding in trials and keeping it all the Halloween movies that you wrote. Like a massive, massive fan. Oh, thank you so much. That's a big. That's a big. The first time I saw you was in foot fist way. Yeah. Blooming the F away still holds up such a funny mother fuck. Have you shown Archie and Abel that film? No, you know what?
I need to show a great friend. I need to show a great friend. What is it? I just saw Jody recently. Did he tell you that? J I just saw Jody recently. Did he tell you that? Jody Hill. Jody Hill.
And we worked together briefly on this commercial a couple months ago. I told him to say hello. I bet you he didn't. He kept that for himself. You know, he doesn't want my head to get too greedy. Yeah. I told him to say, I do. And but we were talking about foot fistway.
And I love that movie so much and I wish you could tell us a little bit about how that came about. Because I was just so curious. Do yourself a favor and check that out. I'm sorry, I haven't seen it. Sean, you're gonna fucking love it. Walk us through it, Danny.
It does. It was one of the first things that I ever did. Jody and myself went to film school together back in North Carolina. And we were living out in Los Angeles for a few years. He was like working on the writing staff of like road rules. I was doing this. Uh, road rules. He had the best job out of all of us.
Yeah, writing staff on road rules. Yeah, somebody's got to put all that together. Sure. He was doing it. Amazing. And I was a cameraman at the time. I was out there at the time. I was out there like doing this thing called motion control
that now it's been replaced by computers. But you know those Ken Burns documentaries where there's photographs and it like pushes and pulls out. That used to be done by hand, my hand. And so I used to do behind the music, history, channel, dog town and Z-boys, that documentary, I worked on all of that stuff. But it wasn't what we had come out to LA to do,
to fill, to fill, still photographs. Yeah, that wasn't your goal, wasn't your goal to go and shoot photographs. Still photographs. Why not? Camera on a slider on a lock off and his push. Yeah.
Wow. I didn't get it, Danny. You need a little slower, please. Got it. That is what it was every day. But easier than working with actors. Uh huh. Yes.
So Jody and I were out there for a few years in Los Angeles. And yeah, we wrote that script together and then went back to North Carolina and shot it for like 70 grand and wow. It got into like the midnight screenings at Sundance and then yeah, Will Ferrell and Adam McKay saw it and then they picked it up and then basically just like changed all of our lives like, you know, within months of that being at Sundance, we sold Eastbound and down. We had, you know, got into like, will I work with you on Hot Rod? That was the very first real paycheck I got was that.
And then Jason, I think I saw you in the audience at Tropic Thunder, right? Did it not cross pass with you there? Yes, sir. Yeah. And we, and we weren't in the scene together and up in the air, but we're both in that film. Yes, yes.
Um, I auditioned for that same part, Jason. Seriously, I really did. In up in the air? Yeah. No way. For Jason's part? Yeah. That's so awesome. Have you ever, is this the first time you're revealing this?
Yes. I think so. I've never heard that before. Killing, let's just see how different the character would be. Jake, do the line and then Sean, let's see your, okay. Try, go ahead. Jake, do you remember any dialogue? George, we're going to have to let the character would be. Jake, do the light and then Sean, let's see your okay. Go ahead. Jake, do you remember any dialogue? George, we're gonna have to let you go.
Good. George, we're gonna have to let you go. Okay, so now I'm kind of seeing, I'm kind of seeing the difference, right, it's a different take for sure. It's a whole different thing. It's a different one. It was a comedy when Sean read for it.
It's a different one. Yeah, they swish genres. All right, now, so Danny, first of all, listener, foot fist way, if you like, if you like films about a Wiley Dojo owner, get in there and watch that. Well, my buddy, my buddy Eli, when we were working together, Eli was a friend of the podcast, and we were working with Jody. Eli kept going off about full-fouced weight because he kept saying,
I just love Mal Karate so much. He's like, and Eli's like, I just grew up in Halifax, we had Mal Karate, I grew up on Mal Karate. And when it stopped saying Mal Karate, but that movie was really such a testament to, to a couple of dudes who were really talented, who were like, you know what?
This is by the way kind of like pre, what, I hate the term content, but pre sort of content, pre people making YouTube videos and having access to do whatever the fuck they want. You guys want an actually made a movie. You didn't just make like a 30 second video where you say something snarky or dumb. You actually wrote a movie and did it, which I- And it wasn't, yeah, and it was kind of a high-wire act because- Fuck yeah. No one's asking for a laugh in that movie.
You're playing a guy who's real tough to like on- So committed, so committed. Yeah, you just never winked once and it started this sort of you own this, this ability to be just repulsive but incredibly likable and, and, and, and people give you a pass. Like, do you have any idea what that secret sauce is of, of, of being a, a lovable dick? I have no clue.
Oh good, I was for Danny, shit. So glad the question was for Danny. Yeah. You know, I don't know. I think with all this stuff that we've kind of mind whether it's like foot fistway or even Eastbound, I think it's just the fact that we just try to make sure that the character is, you know, feels real
and has dimensions. So that like, you're, it's not just throwing out dickish behavior for dickish behavior, but there's underneath of it, you can kind of see some dimension and maybe understand a little bit where it's coming from, you know, there's more to digest. It's usually a lovingly ignorant
or uneducated or something that kind of allows for it, right? It's not, you're not being hateful. Well, I think that probably, I don't know, Danny, correct me if I'm wrong or if you disagree with this, but I think that there is that notion of, like I said before, when you're so committed to the character, as long as you stay committed to it, and like you say, and you can't ever,
people accuse me all the time of playing assholes. I'm like, I don't see them as assholes. I see them as pretty flawed. Yeah, they're just flawed and their sense of what their sense of reality is different from other people's, but they're committed to it. 100%. And they're broken. And I think there's a similarity there. I think that you tap into that. These are characters that are broken. Like, yeah, he's not just being a dick. He's a dick in this moment because shit happened to him that made him act this. And there's a necessary dumbness there, right?
Because if you were smarter, you'd be nicer. And I always care. Yes, that's right. You'd fake it. You know, and some of it just comes from too, when we were writing, you know, we would try to write scripts that where the protagonist
was friendly or had like, you know, noble instincts. And it always would just take the script down so, you know, like predictable pass. And when you start aligning the movie behind the back, what would typically be the bad guy in the story, it just suddenly becomes more interesting. There's like more to do do and you confuse the fuck out of the audience too when they're not sure if you should be celebrating this person or what you're trying to do. Now, what about when have you written despicable characters and given them to other people to play and just like what is that process like for you? Where, because so much of what you write
is dependent on how you perform it to make that combination palatable, right? So how do you enjoy that process of giving it over to someone else? I think it's pretty fun. I mean, like what we'll do even on like, you know, the righteous gemstones, which, you know, that new new season coming out here very soon very
18 June 18th right just gemstones max what max I Think sometimes you know with that a lot of characters and that are on savory and I think it's like We'll try to find the comedy in the behavior as opposed to like a punchline So that like the actor could really get their head around behavior where like the delivery of a specific line is open to interpretation. But it kind of feels like when we really get in there with bringing anybody into our circle,
if the behavior makes sense, then I feel like a lot of people can step in. Is that where you think people go wrong the most is getting that backwards? I think so. I think sometimes you try to be shocking with what a character says, but I think to try to figure out what a character does and make that more shocking is kind of more interesting. You know what I was fine when you get into, when you write characters like that and you
work on things where on the page they seem super unlikable. We always, Jay, we used to talk about this all the time when we were making rest of the development, which is the writers would do a really amazing job of making these characters despicable and funny, but it was always our job to try and make them likable to kind of counteract that. And that's, and if you look that out on the page,
you'd be like, fuck, what, there's nothing, this character sucks, like this guy's a total dick. And I've noticed in other things that I've worked on something I just wrote recently, where you're like, trust me, I know that on the page it looks like X, it's gonna be Y. But if you just read it in a vacuum, right? And I imagine on gemstones, it must be like that. If you read a bunch of those scripts,
you'd be like, what the fuck, man? These guys are dicks. But it's also so reliant on like, you got Adam Devine and John Goodman in there who really know exactly what we're talking about, how to do it so well, play these deeply flawed, broken people that end up being, you know, really lovable. Danny, let me ask you this,
because I've mentioned this a few times, and I think that you're starting to follow it. I think you're already in this category. I maintain that John Goodman has never turned in a bad performance in his life. And he's been in some bad movies. Sure, everybody has. He's never turned in a bad performance. He hasn't.
He's awesome. And I mean, we're always like blown away that we get to work with him, but you know, you just look back and I mean, he was making TV shows, you know, when TV wasn't even cool and he was still able to show up in the Cohen brothers and remember him and revenge in the nerds. Yes. Wow. Dude, dude, revenge in the nerds, he's the coach and he goes, he goes, you got beat and he takes his hat off and he goes, buy a bunch of birds.
And it's one of the funniest, to me, it's one of the funniest readings of a line a whole lot of time, because he's talking about nerds. Yeah, so mad that he takes his hat off and throws it. That's really funny. And we will be right back. Smartless is sponsored by Smart Water.
So, you know, when you're acting on stage for a long time, and you sweat, and you sweat, and you sweat, that's what happened to me, and I came home the other day, and I was had a massive headache, and I was like, what the heck's going on? It's got to say, what's wrong? I was like, nothing! And I got really kind of like short and angry,
and he's like, what's your deal? was like, nothing. And I got really kind of like short and angry. And he's like, what's your deal? And I was like, I don't know. He's like, are you hydrated? Like, seriously? He was like, are you hydrated? I just thought you, because I was standing there drenched after I came home from work. And I was like, maybe that's why I have a headache.
Maybe that's why I'm cranky. So I downed smart water. Cause that's what we have here in the house. And it worked. And I became a hyd-mahedic one-way. Sometimes you just don't need aspirin, sometimes you just need water. Here on the podcast, we are smartless, but not smart waterless. Smart water is 100% vapor distilled with a pure crisp taste. It's pH-balanced and offers added electrolytes for taste.
And here's a little tidbit. When I'm done drinking my smart water, I fill it up with regular water from the faucet, and then I water my plants around my apartment here in New York. And when people are over and they see me do that, they think, boy, he must want his plants to drink that premium high quality water. It says here, we're not allowed to say
that smart water makes you smarter, but we can say it's for sipping while you're listening to your favorite podcast, of course. Keep it smart with smart water. We're brought to you in part by Zip Recruiter. You know, I have a lesser known talent than a lot of people know. I can cook stuff. I'm not like lot of people know. I can cook stuff. I'm not like a great chef,
but I will make stuff that will blow your mind and like, for example, sloppy joes. I have the greatest old school sloppy joe recipe that I'm gonna keep at secret. But it's a lot of work. It has like tons of ingredients and stuff in it that you don't, it's not just from a can, like I make it from scratch people.
So I just wanted to say from like soft skills to hard skills like sloppy Joe making, it takes all kinds of talent to make a business successful, especially if you're going to open a restaurant of sloppy Joe's. If you're hiring and you want to find the right combination of talent for your open roles, you need Zippercrooter. And right now you can try it for free at zippercrooter.com slash smartless. How does Zippercrooter find the most spot on people for your roles? Zippercrooter uses powerful technology to find and send you people whose skills and experience
match your job. If you see someone you're really interested in, Zippercrooter lets you easily invite them to apply to your job to increase your chances of getting them before your competition does. No wonder 3.3 million businesses have come to Zippercruder for their hiring needs. Tap into Zippercruder's unmatched talent for finding great candidates. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercruder get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zippercruder 4-free zippercruder.com slash smartless.
Again, that's zippercruder.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S zippercruder, the smartest way to hire. This episode of Smartless is brought to you in part by Fandool. Take your first swing at betting MLB on Fandool and get 10 times your first bet amount in bonus bets up to $200. That's right, just bet 20 bucks and you'll land $200 in bonus bets when are lose. That's 200 you can spend betting everything from the money line to the over under to who
you think is going to the first home run. All on an app that's safe, secure, and super easy to use. Plus, when you win, you get paid instantly. There's no better place to bet on MLB than Fandool America's number one sports book. So sign up today and visit fandool.com slash smartless to get up to $200 in bonus bets. That's fandool.com slash smartless.
Fandool, official partner of Major League Baseball. 21 plus exclusions apply. I see show notes for Fall Disclaimer. And now, back to the show. So Danny, without revealing any names, was there a super duper dick that you grew up with? It's just like, made you laugh or that you kind of model some of this brand of humor as per your own names?
Or revealing names. Or you can reveal them. I don't think it was anyone in particular, but you know, Jody grew up in North Carolina. I grew up in Virginia. And both of us went to a minute film school and an art school. And so I think we were both these kind of guys that grew up in the South, but didn't necessarily like kind
of fit the mold of like what a lot of our neighbors were about. And we would kind of find humor in it instead of like participating. And so I think once we got to school, we just sort of like just swap stories. And you know, Jody worked in a Taikwondo studio. I took ancient Rukurati and we like our our senseys were basically like the same person when we kind of described the weird shit that he used to do. And we just had a lot of I think there was a lot of crossover in the type of people
when he grew up around. And so then we just. And for Tracy, Jody is. Jody Hill. Jody Hill who wrote, created a Eastbound with you, right? Yes. Yeah. Yeah, writer as well.
Yeah. Well, you brought up an interesting part. Just if I could for once, Danny, so you grew up in the South and that you were interested in stuff that was maybe different from what your neighbors, which is a really great way to put it. But what was that experience like? As two guys who are comedians and who are, as you say, don't necessarily fit that mold, what was that experience like?
Sort of, did you feel like an outsider in your own home sometimes or did you? You know, when I was a kid, I don't think I realized it as much. It was sort of like when my friends were like starting to settle down or stay in the town that I grew up in. And you're like, oh, you're becoming that guy now or you're that that fella in the town. I think when we were kids, you would just kind of gravitate towards who kind of, you know, I just was like so into movies and TV that I just sat my ass on the couch a lot of times, just like watching rented movies and watching HBO through a scrambled signal on the TV.
And I was a nerd. I did exactly. Were you? I was, like, I was just so in, like, I was like making movies on like a home video camera when I was like in fifth grade. And, you know, I used to, we didn't have cable, but I would like sit there and I recorded,
I remember just the audio of Mr. Mom when it came on HBO. We didn't have it. And then I would ride around the neighborhood on my bike in a walkman like, Oh wow. To Mr. Mom. Really? No way.
That's wild. Wait, why am I blanking on Mr. Mom? Mr. Mom's an all time great Michael Keith. Michael Keith was the the one believably great movie. Yeah, great. Right. Yeah. He was a name of the movie that he did where he went over to Japan and worked in an auto. No, they came over here. Oh, that's right. Sorry. Didn't see that one either. Wait, daddy. Do you ever like? I do. I do Michael Keaton, it's the only impression I do. I love Michael Keaton. I just ran into him the other day too.
I'm always like, wait, you guys came over to hear the bike car company? Listener, the face is, is the face is doing it. What can you do in it? It's not the voice. It's the face. It's still sound like what the face is doing a lot of the work. Yeah. Do you ever write something, finish it, give it to an actor, and then go, damn, and I wish I would have kept that part for myself. You know what? I don't. I never really get. I feel like it's all my creation.
And so I'm like, I, I think the parts when I'm in shows that I'm on screen are the parts I enjoy the least. I love watching other people like do it and take it and run with it. That's it. Yeah, it's going to be super satisfying. And then what about when you read something and you go, Oh, I could, I could play this character and you get like a real specific take on it, which I'm, that it's a definition of what you do.
And then you're not auditioning anymore. So you show up on set and everyone's about to see for the first time who they've hired and what version of this character we're gonna get. And here comes the dynamic bride special. Is there any like, have you, as a director, ever pulled you aside and go, hey man, so like Ridley Scott, for example.
Did you read for that or did he know who he was hiring? Yeah, I want you to do something comedic because it's obviously not a comedy. You know, he, I had a meeting with him. He called me in for a meeting and I was like blown away. I mean, I love that franchise and he, you know, is especially. You are so good in that. Yeah, I appreciate that. Thank you.
I mean, I was so nervous to go in there because the same thing, I'm like, I don't want to, I like these movies. I don't want to ruin them by being in it. Like when it comes up, it somehow takes people out of it. And he kind of, he was just sort of of on the mindset where he said that, like what he does is he just is the guard rail. He'll, he'll put people in his movies that have a distinct personality. And he just lets them be them.
And then he'll be there in case anybody's going too far off the rails, but you know, the other thing it was awesome about me. Bill Paxton in the first one was a pretty great, right? That's what I kept watching. He was like, he'd build nailed this. He was incredible in this world. And the other thing is he does like everything on that movie was like five cameras at all times.
Like every so you it was like two takes of something and then he would move on. It's the only movie I've ever been on that finished like two or three weeks had a schedule. Like every day you'd come in. And if you're like, here's what I'm shooting today. And this is in case we get through this, this is tomorrow's sides. And you would get to it all the time. So when you got on that ship for alien covenant, what was that set like? Is it as cool to be honest as it is to see?
You guys, I mean, I got this one. Hey, Sean, you know they, they're in shooting space, right? Yeah, and they build it. It's on a movie studio. Wait a minute. What single tear? No, it's, it was all built. I mean, you rolled into the sound stage and that, that ship was for real in there. No, walk through every fall of it. You could sit there. And he designs it so the cameras are like hidden within the set. So that's how he can get so many shots in every, like a Ridley Scott movie.
It's not like, you know, only one of the shots is good in the rest or things he'd never use. It's all designed. But for the actors, it was kind of awesome because behind the scenes, everybody was so nervous about the fact that he was only doing like two takes. It's almost like they come prepared as if it's live, theater or something where people just know
that you're not gonna have the ability to kind of find it on the day. You just kind of have to come with it, and then it's gone, you know? That's kind of a great, yeah, that's a great device to keep everybody on their toes a little bit. Yeah, why not? Totally, totally.
I should do that. We should do a comedy space thing, but like full scale like that. Like, you know, like not like space balls was a great movie, but yeah, that was sort of like on on purpose. It kind of was meant to be a little low-fi, a little low tech. But if you did it like on the Ridley Scott scale, no one winking, you know. What if somebody's got something in their eyes? So it looks like they're winking. Then it's a tick. And you need to be sensitive.
You're not. Can I ask you a question? Unless Jay, you want to ask that one? This is what it's here for. Yeah, that's what the whole thing is. I'm sorry, but I guess you're still taking questions. Yeah, I'm just sort of a little bit longer. I'll be here.
Yeah. Yeah. So wait, so when I was a kid, one of my favorite movies was... It seems less like a question, more like it's just a story. Tell us about yourself. No, when I was a kid, I was obsessed with the movie Halloween. And I watched the making of it, the behind the scenes, and there's this new series on, I don't know,
where they do, like, the revisit, how they made it. Are you just trying to highlight the fact that you had cable and the Danny didn't, because he just said he didn't have cable growing up. Yeah. And now you're talking, I watched behind the scenes. I watched on the other channel. I watched this. No, this is like a fucking...
This is not a question. This is a fuck you to Danny McBride. No, this is sadly a year ago. Oh, okay. Okay. No, but no, I've always been really into that movie because it was, I grew up on it and it was wild. So the fact that you wrote the newest ones, which are so, you know, I've always been really into that movie because I grew up on it and I was wild. So the fact that you wrote the newest ones,
which are so, I have to tell you, when the first one, I saw the trailer for the first one to come out, I was like, oh God, I hope they get this right. It's so important to me and so many fans. And boy, my God, it was amazing. It was incredible how you re-imagined it. And then all three of them.
And the last one, I loved. It solved so many things. I loved the whole thing. Yeah, how did that come about? You know, one of the other cohorts that I moved to Charleston with is David Green, who's also a director. Yeah, he did a great job. Right before we moved out of Los Angeles, well, even getting to Charleston, I'll explain
that because that has something to do with Halloween. We shot, I'd never really even been to Charleston before. We shot vice principals down here in Charleston and lived here for like six months. Yeah, that's a fantastic show, man. Yeah, thank you. And we all have kids around the same age. Everybody's kids were like between three and five
when we were shooting vice principals. And we were just, we all lived in LA, we were here for like six months, and then we all went back to Los Angeles. And then after a few months, everyone just started sort of like, man, I really miss it down there. Like sometimes I think it would be cool to just like live there.
Would you ever, and everyone started talking, and it turned into this thing where like, we ended up as like almost like 10 families, that all the dudes went one weekend to go sus it out, and then the wives went, and then everybody kind of ended up, it was like almost like 10 families that all the dudes went one weekend to go sus it out and then the wives went and then everybody kind of met up we're like, are we gonna do this? So we're gonna move to Charleston with our whole crew and everybody did it and like, it was like six years ago
and so part of it was like we need to bring work down here. We need to like try to pump this industry up down here and so Halloween was the first thing we sort of did. David and I signed up for that. We're like, this will be a cool project to bring down there and to get people working. So you shot it there. We shot it here, yeah.
Wow. Yes, so David had been got approached by Jason Blum to see if he was interested in adapting it. And David knew I was a really big fan of it and asked me what I thought. And I had the same kind of reaction as you. I was like, fuck, I just love the series so much that it would suck to create something that diminished it.
And then the more we thought, we're like, well, somebody's gonna do it. So maybe we'll have a better shot of creating it because we really care about it coming out good. I guess anyone would, but- So- Not to out of the park. We just, we had a blast.
And I think we never thought about the pressure of it Yeah, you know, I guess anyone would but not out of the park. We just we had a blast And I think we never thought about the pressure of it because I feel like I Was sort of my own worst critic on it. I was like, you know I'm always like convinced I'm gonna ruin things that I touched that I didn't all the way So I didn't want to you know, I was so nervous about it I think it didn't really register like the weight of the fans and everything until it premiered at the Toronto Film Festival.
And when I saw the crowd and the amount of people that were lined up and people in the masks and the shirts, there was just this moment with Dave and I were like, fuck, this doesn't work. We are about to, like this is a rabid fan base and they're going to destroy us. You can get killed by 500 Michael Myers. Oh, that's what I thought. That's what I really thought was going to be. And it was such a gratifying feeling
when we screened it there into field the audience in it at the end and there applauding and clad. It was probably one of the coolest moments of anything in my career, that moment there with the fans was so much fun. So what you were saying earlier, you really did the work about the characters because if that's not there, it would have been such a failure.
But really like the backstory and the relationships and everything is what made it so great. Yeah, that's what we like love. I think a lot of the stuff we're influenced by is a lot of that 70's cinema, which would be character pieces and not necessarily story driven, but sort of, you know, just pieces around characters that are interesting. And so I think we tried to apply that idea to our take on Halloween
and see what we could do with that. So good. What's your, what's your ideal frequency of working? You're down there, you got all your, your friends and colleagues down there. Do you guys like to always have something that you're shooting and at the same time kind of working on what the next thing might be or uses it one thing at a time and you're good to just kind of be shooting only one thing every kind of year and a half or two years or something. You know, gemstones is about 15 months between
like writing it and then shooting it and then and post and so that's taken I've been on that, you know, one one season right after the next but it was funny I moved here because I kind of was feeling like I was working too much when I was in Los Angeles. I didn't know how to like shut it down. My kids were starting to kind of like take notice of me being gone. And so I sort of like sold it to my wife that like moving to Charleston, we'd be able to chill. And I think we could like, busier here. Is your wife from, is your wife from the South?
She's not. She's from Los Angeles. And so she, she was, I really wanted to make sure she was okay with this because I, I kind of appreciate the, uh, the, uh, I don't know, I appreciate all the, the, the weird, strange things about the South and, and that, not everyone does. And, uh, so I didn't think I was wanting to make sure she was going to dig it, but she loves it here. And then her mom is an Angelino. She moved here just a few years ago, fallin' us down here too.
And it's been awesome. It's been a lot of fun. Now, the way that you're describing it, I love Charleston. And I actually really like this out too. And so I was like, I'm kinda jealous the way you're talking about it. And like, I know, fuck it up.
Maybe we should, guys, should we just move Charleston and be like, I know. Everybody talks about it, but you guys did it. Let's talk to show on the road. Does your wife work with you at all? She does it not now. just moves. Carlson, me, everybody talks about it, but you guys did it. Let's talk to show in the road. Does your wife work with you at all? She does it, not now. She was a, she was a private chef for a while when I met her.
She was, she would like translate for deaf and blind students at UCLA. And that's what she was doing when I met her. And then she became a personal chef for a while. And yeah, now she's like, she's an artist too. She like makes bags and paints. And so she's been, she's an artist too. She like makes bags and paints and stuff. She's been so pretty busy down here. Do you find that your kids are looking at what you do
as something that they might wanna do or they like our kids, they don't give it up. They're like, they don't give it up. My daughter kind of gives it up. My daughter is eight years old and she loves everything that we do. She sees it. She goes to school and you tubes me and like, we'll come home saying stuff.
Come on. She's like, she should not be saying anything. Oh really? And my son doesn't give it up at all. I mean, I think you would rather do anything, but what I'm doing probably. What's Declan into right now? Declan is into right now.
What is he into? See a sports guy? Is he a sports guy? Is he a video game guy? He is. He's video games. He's kind of whatever like all his friends are playing in sports at the time. And you know, he has it all. Like the kind of the cool thing about where we live is the kids can actually just like go
outside and go jam. You know, like when we first, we've got a LA, my son was like asking me, like if I would teach him how to ride a bike, and I'm like, why? Yeah, you're never gonna take a bike ride off a moha on up here. Yeah. Yeah, so sidewalks, it's all hell.
Unless you want me to drive you to a parking lot and watch you drive around in circles and stuff. Yeah, dude, that's what I do. That's how I do. I had to put a bike in the back of my car. We live up here in Moha on to the drive three miles to a park to teach my kid how to ride. And now they can't use it because there's nowhere to ride.
So he's into that. The outdoors is like, you know, I mean, it's kind of wild like the other day. So there's a knock in the door and there's like 10 kids on bikes like Declan here, you know, and they all love that. I love that. That's how they go. I got to get like a playstation or an Xbox or something for Maple because Willie, we came over to your house the other night and Maple went upstairs and Able and her played
video games for a couple hours. I went up there and watched a little bit. It's incredible. Like, I grew up on a Tari and in television and the graphics, the complexity, it's so bitching. I mean, I think it would be, I mean, I got to get it from me, let alone her. I got to an Xbox a few years ago. We played for a minute, but I, you know, that Xbox came from you. Yeah, man. Yeah. It's sitting in there. We played us, what was a super, some superhero thing for a little while,
and then that was it. But I'm talking about, they were playing Fortnite, and this is just like, what a world that is. I played with, I played with, like years and years and years ago, you called me, or you got me Call of Duty, or one of those games. Yeah, yeah, I played it, yeah, with the headset, and I played it for a minute, and I was like,
I couldn't get out the door without getting shot over and over again. Like, we got it, well, with the headset. And I played it for a minute. And I was like, I couldn't get out the door without getting shot over and over again. Like, we got it. Well, remember we talked about with Krizenski, God made us all play when it first came out in 2007. And Thoreau, who you did, your highness, we're off with him. And Travathunder, I was wondering,
did, I'm trying to remember if you were sleeves in your highness. No, probably not sleeves, I don't know. So, did you guys had a little call of No, probably not sleeves. I don't know. Right. So did you guys had a little call of duty lead going? But we had a legal ingestion was like, we used to, I remember years ago, Thoreau and I were out. It was a real great look.
A bunch of 40-year-olds. We were out for dinner. We were out for dinner with our ladies. We were at the time, almost 40, and he'd go, and he and I are trying to wrap up dinner real early and we're like eating a stuff that we got the check because there were a bunch of dudes were all gonna be playing online and finally one of the ladies goes, are you fucking guys rushing us out of dinner so you can get home to play your fucking video game?
What? What? What? What's you? What's crowd dare you? After that I went back to my Super Mario brothers. Danny, listen, do you miss anything about LA that you so had readily available
that maybe anything at all? Yeah, I mean, I love living out in Los Angeles. I really did. I lived there for almost 20 years and so lots of friends and Mexican food and... Yeah. But it's been cool. It's been a nice change and it gets me up to New York more.
I go and finish a post on the show up in New York and oh, really? I love being up there. So so this slow. Not I've just never been. I just imagine because it's not a major city. Sean, you've never been in Charleston, South Carolina. No, it's going to blow your mind. I would love to go.
It's going to let me take you. Come on. Let me show you my Charleston. But, but does it does these for I don't mean this to be insulting in any way to anybody. That is the slower. It's I imagine it's slower than a big city. Whoa. That's something you miss. It is slower and I think I was so tuned to Los Angeles that like when I went back to Los Angeles after living here for a few months, I really found myself like not able to keep up.
I was like, God, it's just so loud and crowded here and kind of like I was used to it. I, you know, everybody here is just super friendly which when we moved here, every for a week, people were coming by and just bringing baked goods to our house. And then one time we came home and they had just like laid it inside the house. Like they had opened up the front door and just like put the cup things.
You sure had blown off in Los Angeles. And you go, oh my God. I know. I do want to, I, that's something about that seems so peel. We know it's funny. Like Abel was telling me the other day, Abel's my 12 year old and he was telling me that he'd gone to a friend's house. I picked him up and I said, how was he?
He's like, it was pretty good. We went to this other person's house. I picked him up and I said, how was he? He's like, it was pretty good. We went to this other person's house. We walked over, which is unusual, right? We like, we walked over from so-and-so's house back to Jonas's house. I was like, cool. And he goes, and we played, you know, Ding Dong ditch, whatever, you know, it's got so many different names, but you know, playing Ding Dong ditch and I went, hey man, no, you can't do that in Los Angeles.
It's true. Because people get fucking, yeah, I was like, no, no, no, no. Yeah. It's such a bummer. Yeah, it's such a bummer that you can't do that unless Angeles. It's true because people get fucking, yeah, I was like, no, no, no. Yeah, it's such a bummer. Yeah, it's such a bummer that you can't go. And Charleston, you can still egg houses probably. You definitely can still egg houses, yeah. Like this, this sound nice, art like our, we have this older couple that lives next door to us.
And they're so awesome. They're so friendly, so nice. And last summer, there was like a hurricane that came through here. And we were shooting gemstones. It was one of those things where we had a decide, like, are we gonna shut down production? Are we gonna let people go home?
Like, is this gonna come? Is it gonna hit us? And we ended up like shutting down production. People went home, but we shut it down. Like the day it was arriving. And so my wife and one of our friends like scurried around the house, like trying to like secure the stuff outside from blowing around.
And so they did all that and I come home. We just like decide we're going to wait the hurricane out. We're just going to drink wine and chill and like watch it. And so that's what we do. And it's a blast. We're having a great time watching. If you can get inside the actual eye. That's the same. We're hearing each other to run outside. But people like, right, as the worst part of the storm passed, our next door neighbor like texts my wife. And she's like, oh, this is horrible. And my wife was like, oh, it's fine.
Just drink some wine. It's great. It's like, it's almost done. And she's like, no, this is horrible. And she sends a picture of this 25 pound dumbbell from our gym underneath the house and it had flown through their second story window and was like sitting in their dining room. She's bust through.
And I'm like, what the fuck, how would that have happened? How would a weight have gotten up there? And so I go downstairs where the gym is, the garage door shut, everything's in there. I'm like, what the fuck, how did this get up there? And then I look out in the backyard, I'm like, the trampoline. Where's the trampoline? And so I go up in my wife and her friend had put the weights on the trampoline to wait now. And then, I got a win, took it and it fucking sailed.
It's like, it flew up in the air and flew into the front yard and threw the dumbbell right through their window. I thought for sure, I thought it was so mortified. I had no idea what we should do. Like, when we go over now, do we let them come to our house and they, they never were bothered by it. They were so friendly. Oh, it's not your fault. They actually baked you a fresh baked. They were like, incredible. I'm like, this would have been out. This could have been worse. This could have been a waste. Sean, Sean, didn't you tell me about a club you went to once where everything that wasn't tied down got blown?
I think it was called dumbbells too, wasn't it? Yeah, I just, after a while they let me in. I didn't have to see the bounce or anything. That's so fucking crazy though. What an awesome story. Honestly, Sean, I, because I know Sean, every time Sean goes to a different, and Jay's like this too, actually, I think everybody is, but every time he go to a different place, Sean's, I was like, I want to move you.
So I was looking at real estate. Yeah, I do. I'm meeting with Sean. I'm really looking at links. I know. It's amazing. And, and so I think that if Sean were to come, Sean, if you were to go down to South Carolina, you would be like, sorry man,
we're moving to South Carolina. I know I have a couple of friends that live there, and I know I just never been there. And now, a word from our sponsor. Thanks to GoodRx for supporting the show. Summer is in full swing, and we're all looking for ways to save money for road trips, stay-cations, or I don't know know summer camp for the kids. You may not expect to find a
deal at the pharmacy counter but hey with goodRx you can instantly save up to 80% on your prescription medications. Using goodRx is easy and totally free. All you need to do is search for your prescription on the goodRx website or app and show your discount at the pharmacy. With goodRx you can find prescription savings at the pharmacies right in your neighborhood including CVS, Walgreens, RIDade, Vans, Walmart, Sam's Club, and many more. And remember good Rx works whether you have insurance or not. Even if you have insurance goodRx could possibly beat your copay price. So when you're filling prescriptions a summer, don't forget to check goodRx before you get to the pharmacy.
I have a medication that I have to take every day, a very specific medication, and GoodRx helped me save when I went to the counter at my pharmacy. And it was awesome. I was like, oh my god, I saved all this money. So why am I at the pharmacy? I can just grab a pack of all these candy bars. That's what I did, by the way.
For simple smart savings on your prescriptions, check GoodRx, go to goodrx.com slash smartless. That's goodrx.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. It's a lot of golf down there, Danny. Do you play golf at all? I've played. I'm not any good, but I definitely,
you have to go out, you have to get, I mean, everyone golfs down here. There's some pretty cool spots, too. But what about the heat? Good Lord. I think I've got the ocean to jump in. Yeah, and you know, it's only really bad in the summertime. The rest of the year, it's pretty mild.
It's great, but I feel like even if it's humid or if it's not humid, if it's above like 85, regardless, my ass is inside anyway. I'm not going to be in that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, I want to, I really is inside anyway. I'm not gonna be, I'm just saying that. Well, I really wanna go. Tell us about what that moment was when, so Will Farrell and Adam McKay, they see FootFist way, they say, yes, please, we wanna work it.
What was that start of that collaboration or that relationship with those guys like and them sort of nurturing you and validating you? And was that, did you know at the time that, okay, this is a nice greased path into what we really want to do? Or did you think it was just kind of like a one time thing? We had no clue.
I mean, honestly, we were so, it was funny. Like I went to film school and I had been kind of trying to do this. I wasn't trying to be an actor. I went to film school for writing and directing. And you know, but then when the moment came, it was sort of like we were just kind of both of us were shocked. I mean, it was like we went from like, you know, just doing our day jobs to suddenly like meeting our heroes and meeting people that were doing it for
living. And it was an incredible like time period. And you know, Adam and Will set us down and asked us what we wanted to do next. And that's when we pitched them Eastbound and down. And they were kind of confused that we wanted to make a TV show. They're like, well, most people try to make TV shows to get movies. You know, like you already have the movie. You don't need to do the TV show. And you were like, yeah, I don't know. There's something about this.
We just, we feel like it would work better as a TV show. And yeah, I feel like that show is good. That being attached is the only reason I think why the show stayed alive. You know, we sold that show to a different regime at HBO. And then, you know, I think when the new people showed up, I think they were kind of like, what did we buy? Like, what is this? Like, I remember seeing, we are, we're like, had a week left to shoot and we got these
panic calls. I think it was the first time that anyone had watched what we were doing down in North Carolina. And they were asking like, can you give Kenny Powers like a dog? Can he have a kid that he helps? Like, anything that we can do in the last week here to make this guy more likeable. What was, where did the, are you a baseball fan? Where did the, where did the, the, the world come from?
You know, that's like I, I wasn't a baseball fan. I mean, I am now, You know, that's like, I wasn't a bass player. I mean, I am now, but that's the thing. When I was writing it, I never even thought about that I would need to know how to throw or pitch right. Until we got down to shoot the pilot, and they like, do we need to get a specialist or something? I'm like, yeah, sure. So we got this guy from the local college,
and he's like, let me see what you have. And I threw a ball. He's like, oh, Jesus. So we got this guy from the local college. And he's like, let me see what you have. And I threw a ball. He's like, oh, Jesus, good thing this is a comedy. It's like, you know, so I was like constantly being like, well, he's a failed pitcher, right? Yeah, there's a reason he's not doing well. So every time I throw the ball, it always like punches in right past me.
You never were able to see my full form. Oh my God. I have a question about like for all three of you guys. Go for Sean. Yeah, sure. Thank you. I give this question about like for all three of you guys. Go for Sean. Sure, thank you. Again, this is a great venue for your questions. When you, Danny, when you, and by the way, I want to know, Jason, with you directing and writing Will, I know you've all written and starred in something or directed and starred
in something. Is it a lot like the older you get? Are you feeling like, you know, it's really great to wear a lot of hats, but maybe just the one hat now is fine. Like, where you prefer just to show up and know your lines as an actor and then go home. Or do you still enjoy doing it all? I like that every once in a while,
just to show up and wait for them to knock on the trailer and say time to come out and talk, and then you do that for about 10 minutes and then you go back. Yeah, because it just seems like an overwhelming amount of... I find it the reverse, the older I get, the more I just wanna do this stuff that I create. Yeah.
Yeah. And work hard, hard, hard, yeah. Yeah, but I did work hard, but also like then you get to control and Danny's been doing it for a long time. I know, that's why I was asking like Danny also, like, then you get to control, and Danny's been doing it for a long time. I know, that's why I was asking, like, Danny, too. Like, don't you, I'm just thinking about the Halloween things or anything,
where you write, but then you go run off an act and now this show that you're in right now, you're doing both, it just seems like a lot. It is a lot, you know, show running is definitely difficult, I mean, that kind of process of having to deal with the scripts at the same time you're dealing with production and it's a ton. And then go have to, and then act.
And then you have to know your lines. Yeah, have your energy up for it. I just like the collaboration of filmmaking a lot. Like I love working with the guys that I direct with. So sometimes I just get lonely if it's just me directing. It's like, it's just on the only one here. And where I like working with the other guys, I like what we come up with together.
I think there's something fun about that. Danny, are you watching somebody or something right now that's keeping you kind of motivated and thinking forward? And like, I don't know, I was thinking for, we were talking about Halloween and combining comedy and filmmaking and all this stuff. Like Jordan Peel's a really exciting guy nowadays. It gets me really, really excited in that world.
Are you watching him or somebody like that that's floating your boat? Yeah, I definitely like him a lot. You know, like, weirdly, when it comes to TV stuff, I find myself just watching like reality TV. Like, my brain just doesn't want to commit to anything. So, like I'm all about the Vanderpumps right now. That should on fire. Right. Everybody.
It is a wipe out. Is it? It's so good. Do you watch it, Jay? Yeah, I've seen it. It's just I just I love all that. And it's also just the way they make those shows now, the whole reality world. It's really well done, you know, like they've figured it out.
There's a format there and they're starting to play with the form a little bit too. And it's, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, we know Andy, we talked about Andy Cohen. I know Andy a little bit, and I saw a few clips recently. I guess some shit went down on Vanderpump recently that blew everybody's mind. There's like a fair, and a, oh yeah, there's a whole thing. And people don't like this person. Here's the thing, they talk about them like their characters. And so they have them on these follow-up shows
and they're like, well, I think at that moment that so and so did this, I think that she's really coming to terms with them like, wait, this is not, you're talking about it. They're the real people. And she's sitting next to you. And she's sitting next to you. And you're talking like she's really making decisions that I don't think that she understands.
And you're like, wait, what the fuck are we talking about, man? Yeah, it's strange. What is happening? It's so strange. It's so hard. They must fight the instinct or maybe they're asked to cause trouble, but you kind of fight the instinct to cause trouble to make for good drama probably. So I wonder how much of it is them trying to really contribute. That's what it's got to
be. I mean, even the fact that like so many of these reality shows are on ensembles, you know, and it seems like everyone's fighting for their, you know, for their notoriety or for how they leave their mark become the most exciting Train for their water cooler moment. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's a true Vanderpump. I gotta watch it now. This season has been phenomenal It's how many so long as about you know, I stopped watching it for a while And then I heard the news about the affair that happened and I was I was like, I need to tune back in and see what these Vanderpump's been up to. And, uh, guys, Vanderpump, their name, no, it's Lisa Vanderpump is the lady who owns the restaurant. They all work out, but I like just saying it plural. I just think it sounds fun. Vanderpump 's, but wait, wait, that's what they'll ask you. That's somebody's last name on the show.
Yeah. And wait, and all these people work at her restaurant? That's right, yep. I still watch the Jersey Shore. You still watch the Jersey Shore, huh? I still watch it. But just for the big, burly dudes. Yeah. All right, so now you're power down for the summer, where are you and your little band of criminals
going for the summer? Are you gonna take a big vacation? I think I am. My kids have never of criminals going for the summer. You're going to take a big vacation. I think I am. My kids have never really been outside of the country. So I think we've locked, we're going to do a straight up big European vacation. Yeah, that's good. We're going to Griswold,
and we're going to France to Italy, we're going to go to Germany. It's going to be awesome. So this is going to be one week, two weeks, three weeks? It's going to be seven weeks. Come on. Everybody's going to pick one little suitcase. That's our deal. And we're meeting different people on the way. Walton Goggins, a him or a love Walton. We've rented a fortress in Sicily for a week. So I'll see his family at one point. Now are you going to drive like the Griswolds? Are you going to take trains or is it going
to be a combination of all? It's a combo of both. I'm gonna try to run a car as much as I can. I just wanna get the full experience, but we'll train it up a little bit too. Seven. I tell you what, driving in Italy is the best because you think like it's, people are like, no, that must be insane. I'm like, no, it's the best because there's a method
to the madness of it and it makes sense. It's not like here where nobody drives with the, nobody uses a turn signal and all that shit. Everybody's the worst. Over there, it's everything happening. You drive in Germany so you can go without any, any speed limit on the out of the whole thing, right? That's where that's the climax of the vacation. Sure it is. Right. It's okay to help you build because you're at the end. Yeah. She's it. But seven weeks all together, I mean, have you guys done that? Wait, we've never done it before. Yeah. She's it. But seven weeks all together, I mean, have you guys done that?
Wait, we've never done it before. Yeah, we've never done it up. Yeah, I'm looking forward. I felt like now was the time. My son is like starting to get a lot of friends outside of his family circle. And I feel like it will be very hard, I think, in a year to convince him to like hang with his fam for the whole summer. I think now it's now. When you go on trips, guys, like, do you think about like, I think about like, where's the nearest hospital or a doctor or something should happen? Or you know what I mean?
Like, also I bat, like your, what is it called? What does it call the dopamine? No, the bag, the toiletry bag. Well, what is it called? Dog kit, dog kit. That your dog kit should have like all of the like, American, you know, Tylenol and like all the your dog kit should have like all of the like American, you know, Tylenol and like all the stuff that you should have ready.
Okay. So you're real blast to you real blast to hang out with you know, that you are. You're real. You get injured a lot. No one in my family's allowed to get headaches while we're gone. Danny are all the are the family's passports up to date. Have you looked at that? Everybody's up to date.
Yeah. That's a common like good. Yeah. Yeah. Everyone's excited for nothing. Yep. Nope. They're all up to date. I love. I'm so jealous. Why don't we all just move to South Carolina for real? Yeah.
Come to Charleston. Yeah. That's the first time. Let's go to Charleston. It's really nice down there. Oh my God. I can't wait to go. I'm not kidding. I want to go. I'm just jealous. Let me ask you Danny. Do you I know you say you love LA and there's a lot of great things about LA and I'm nice down there. Oh my God. I can't wait to go. I'm not kidding. I want to go. I'm just jealous.
Let me ask you, Dandard, I know you love LA, and there's a lot of great things about LA and New York. But do you kind of relish like being out of the grind a little bit that you get to have this kind of experience that is not just always folk? I know you work a lot, but here sometimes work in social life and all that can just become one because it's such a company town.
Yeah. You kind of relish that that you don't, all your touch points aren't about, like Bateman, every single thing touch point in his life is about show business. Yeah, yeah. My underwear is just a trade paper. It's folded up nice.
Everything is. He can't, everything is within the context the framework of show business. He has no real world experience. No, no. I, you know, I do, I do like that. I like getting away from it. I mean, you know what it's kind of cool about it
is that I felt like when I was in LA, you see billboards everywhere. You're constantly thinking about work. You know, it's just, it's hard to get away from it. And here it's kind of cool because you don't see any of that. There's no billboards for any movies or TV shows are coming out. And then you kind of, it kind of puts it in perspective
what you're doing, you know. They're like, this is just seasoning for people. It's not what the whole thing doesn't revolve around this. And when you entertain people, that's it. That's all you're just giving. Yeah. Well, you know, you can hear this. Yeah, no, that's it. That's all you're you're just Yeah, well, you know, Baby, can you hear this? Yeah, no, but you can hear it's not important, man. Right.
What about when you when you walk into a market, though, do people there do they just they go, oh my god, what what are you what are you doing here? This is a guy on movies and television. You know, people have been pretty cool. I think because I don't know. I think people know that I'm here. And so then they're sort of they're nice. I mean, you got to watch, you know, I don't go to bars or anything late at night when everybody's like, you know, admissions are down or any of that stuff. But yeah, I kind of, I mean, it's fun like going to like my kids just go to public school here. So I mean, like I love going to these like PTA meetings and these things just sitting in the back. I love it. I think it's I will say Danny reminds me of you've got because of a lot of the characters
you've played it you mentioned and we all know that when you run into people after they've had a few cocktails that's when people feel like you're definitely taking a photo with me and you're like, Hey man, I'm eating dinner. I was like, Oh, care. You're taking a photo right now, but you're one you play a lot of these characters that dudes probably come up to you a lot super aggressively when they've had a few. Oh, 100%. Fuck yeah, can he power it?
Like I, I'm, you know, when you hang out with Farrell, he gets out a lot because everybody's like, he's like America's fucking best friend. So we're like, fuck yeah. Yeah, here comes Johnny. Can you tell me, can you're like, all right, man? It's always somebody like you can smell the booze and they're breath, they're putting their sweaty arm around you and they're on their phone trying to show you how they dressed up like you for Halloween. That's always that. That's always what it is.
That's hysterical. Yeah. Yeah. The dinner at 530. That's the key. That is the key. That's the key. That's the best. Danny, we appreciate your time. Thank you for sharing an hour with us, my friend. Wait, tell us again when gemstones is coming out. Gemstones, June 18th on June 18th. And then we're going to need the address of your place there in Charleston while you're gone for seven weeks.
So we can just kind of try it out and stay in your house there. I think you should. So that's a great time to kind of test drive Charleston. I might do some exercise in your backyard on the trampoline with the weights. There you go. The trampoline is gone. All right. Danny, thank you, my friend.
Have a great trip this summer. Everybody watch Gemstones and please come back and talk to us anytime you want. Thanks, Danny. Thank you so much. Thanks for having me on. I really appreciate it. You all take care. You do great to see you, man.
All right. See you, too All right, bye. Bye. There's a guy who's never not funny. It's just me. I love everything he does. And sweet, sweet and funny. Will, wasn't it your handle in high school? Sweet and funny. Sweet and funny, yeah.
Funny, sweet. I'm also kind of like amazed, like that's why I asked that question earlier. I'm so amazed that when people do, I can't imagine like writing and showering and then being in it and like being good in it, like he is like, like Jason, like you are, like when you're Ozark, when you're directed
the thing and then you just jump in front of the camera and act and brilliantly and, I mean, what part could he not play? What movie would you not want him in? He could do the comedy, do the drama. He could just write if you want him not on it. I know. Which he often does as well.
He would direct it. It's so, isn't that rare though? Yeah. It's a rare that somebody can, you can just pick up a pen right apart for yourself in a show that you created and then go make it. Yeah. And he does these shows for like three years at a time and then shuts it down and then starts a brand new one.
Yeah. I want to get into that line of work. I'd like to be his McGrroom. Oh. Wonderful. Anybody? Wonderful. Guys, I love you so much.
I love you. Are you just gonna say goodbye? We're just gonna say goodbye. Well, I gotta go bye-bye because I gotta go to this thing. Oh, cool. go to your thing. It's really great having seen you both today. Sean, you know I heard this show. By the way, you're going to do your play tonight.
Again, you're doing a good job. What's it called, Will? It's called Good Night Oscar. And what theater is it at? And it's at the Chabasco. Chabasco. Chabasco. Chabasco.
Chabasco theater. Oh, man. And by the way, Trabasco. Trabasco. Trabasco, theater. Oh, man. And by the way, it's been doing really well. Very well. And it's been sold out. And in fact, you can't even get a seat, but you can be put on. Stand by your man.
Oh, nice. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness is 100% organic and artisantly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unjurf. Smartness. Jeff. Smug. Loss. Rex Chapman. Hello.
Hello, Rex. Hello, Will. Sean Jason. So great to be here. How was your going? Thank you. Wonderful to meet you. Thank you.
Thank you for talking with us. Yeah. So we got this new podcast with you called owned or very, very excited. You said yes to doing this. Thank you so much. I'm so grateful. You guys asked when they said that Rex Chapman was going to do a podcast with us. I said, how are we possibly going to do a podcast about moonshine? But you know what? They said it's not. It's not. Right. It's not that. It's not that. It's not that. Sports owners. But you are here today because of owned, which is a smartness media podcast that we're so lucky to have you. Yeah. So nice. You said yes to do that. I'm so thankful
you guys. It's fantastic. It's out now. Yeah. It's it's really, really great. Tell us briefly exactly like what what it what it is. And why is it- Talk to the dummies we are. Like maybe like a listener that has no idea what this is about. I'm gonna go. I know I'm gonna bring- Oh, okay, you ready? Now, talk to me now.
All right, here we go. So, you know how you guys with your movies or your TV shows, there's a finance here, a person who's paying the bills, footing the bill. Sometimes those guys, those women, people, they don't know anything about making a movie or a TV show. And I'm sure for you guys, that's pretty frustrating when that person wants to have say
as to what's going on film. It can be a challenge. Well, you're looking at my track record. I don't know anything about making a movie or TV show. So let's be real. Let's call it what it is. But sports ownership is really no different. I mean, there are good owners and they're not so good owners.
And there are bad owners. Most of them are millionaires to billionaires. And they do this for a hobby. Some are very good. Some of them have sports backgrounds. And those owners are usually pretty good to work for and play for. The others though are not just as you might imagine.
They were asking me earlier about some of the owners I had. I played for two owners. The first one was in Charlotte. And that was a guy named George Shin, and he was very cheap, didn't spend a lot. I remember a couple. We got the Transistra radio for Christmas one year, and a monogrammed Bible when he came alive.
Oh my God. Yeah, yeah. And so then I was traded from there and went to Washington and played for the old bullets. A. R. Bullen was the owner. And my first day there, I get to the locker room and we're practicing, we don't have a practice facility. It's at Bowie State University. And it's got a literal play stage on the side of the gym.
It's a high school gym. But we're in there, I'm in there and there's a note school gym. Right. But we're in there. I'm in there and there's a note on my chair by my locker. Very first day and it asks me, says, you can take your gear home and wash it every day or you can pay, have $25 taken out of your check every week so we can pay the equipment manager to wash your shit for you.
Why? So it's a professional basketball, professional basketball team. What year was that? This was 1992. Did you have to drive yourself to away games? No, but we, but in Washington, you're not supposed to take buses and then be anything longer than an hour and a half. So you can travel like Philly to DC maybe.
Right. We traveled all over the East Coast on buses. No. Boston, New York, New Jersey to DC. And, you know, we'd play the next sometimes at home and then play them the next night in the garden and they would beat us home because they flew back after the game.
Sure. And we're driving up on a bus the next day. Wait, and you guys are, and you're not, how tall are you, Rex? Six, three, six, four. Right. So again, I mean, still by NBA standards, maybe not the tallest, but also very tall. Right. And the rest of your teammates, you probably had guys who were six, seven, six, eight,
crammed on a bus. I mean, that's not good for the product. Yeah, it's not good. that's not good for the product. Yeah, it's not good. It's not good for the product. But that was, you know, that was an ownership that just didn't spin. I was traded though. I was traded though from there to Miami.
The Miami Heat who are currently playing, or playing in the NBA finals. Yeah. Great ownership. Mickey Eris and got there. He was one of the first team owners to buy a plane We got a plane our first year so now we're not even flying commercial Which most other teams do yeah, we have our own plane and that changes the whole game and as you guys know to it's not just
Spending on the top players, right? It's not just spending on the you know the the marquee actor It's spending on everybody and making everyone feel loved and valued and that's what the good owners do. I went on to Phoenix and played for Jerry Kalangelo, another great owner. So it just boils down to, you know, which owners are good, which owners are not. And the ones that aren't just kind of back off
and let people do their jobs. And it's not just money. It's also just like, that trickle down effect vibe wise to the whole team is so important, right? From the ownership, no question. And you know, the owners that know your kids and your wife's name and you're, you know,
you're the people that come to the game with you. The owners that, it's no different than life, relations. Yeah, that's what I like about it. Like it's no secret, I'm not a. Yeah, that's what I like about it. Like, it's no secret. I'm not a massive sports fan, but listening to this podcast owned, I'm like really into it because of what you just said, because I love the human stories. Right. And like, I'm really, really into how that all works.
And like, everything you just said, I think it's fascinating. I think you make a great point, Sean. And I probably should have said this. This isn't targeted for sports nuts. This is targeted for people that listen to your guys show who are entertainment people who love storytelling. And are gonna get some of these crazy owners. Yeah, by the way, Rex,
so just speaking of sports nuts, did you wear a cup? No, I didn't, yeah, no, it's a good question. We do that. I think back and why didn't we wear cups, but you also rarely get hit in the balls and basketball. I wore one to high school just so I could feel a little more masculine. But it's fun to sort of vicariously live through these, these own, like how many, how many people said, say boy if I had $10 billion what would you do what would you buy you know and and so to hear about what these massively wealthy people do
with all of that influence and access and and permission. A lot of them do the right thing and a lot of them do the wrong thing and that's kind of some of the stuff you explore yeah. No question the good ones are always fun the bad ones are fun. For instance, we have Rick Riley on. Oh, yeah, I love it. And we did a, we have an episode on Marge Shot. Yeah, we know. Ask Marge Shot. Marge used to say the inward regularly. Wow. She was not, she let her dogs poop on riverfront stadium out there in the field. But Rick was telling us a story. He said, we asked him, you know, any just crazy weird story with Margie said, I don't know where to start, but he came up with one. He went to interview her at her house and she was off chasing the dog around. And he was kind of meandering through the halls. And
She was off chasing the dog around, and he was kind of meandering through the halls, and she walks back, and he pulls out of a drawer, a Nazi arm band. Oh, wow. And he asks, smart, about this, and she just kind of poo-poo-sit and says, oh yeah, just, you know, just something in the drawer there. Little memorabilia.
Little memorabilia. What? And this lady was running the Cincinnati Reds for years and years and years. I mean, see, those are the kind of stories that you don't hear any like, right. And other guests that you've had on Larry Wilmore, Paul Sherr, Russell Crowe, Ike Baronholds, like a lot of people been coming on. It's fantastic. I wasn't sure I wanted to do this with you guys because normally we just,
I had just entertained the, the Oscar winners. We've got Russell Crowe and Natalie Portman, right? Yeah. None of you guys have won Oscars yet. Have you? Now what's Natalie talking about? They didn't give them out for the millers on CBS. Sorry. Go ahead, Rex. Natalie's part of a soccer team, right? Natalie, a women's soccer team. Yes. The LA angel.
FC. Oh, the angels, angels, yes. And, and, um, I mean, it's a partner, huh? Part owner. And they've got a ton of famous actors, entertainers, athletes that own that squad. And it's become a big deal. And they are, they're so mission oriented. They're trying to, yes. Sorry. You should, you should talk to Peter Goober. He's part owner of the Dodgers and love to Golden State Warriors, right? And oh, something else too. I know you've got a connection because you barely miss a Dodgers game, don't you, Jason? Well, I go to about 20 or 30 a year.
Yeah, I love him. Did you guys play, did any of the three of you play sports seriously as a kid? I played everything a little bit except for football. My mother wanted me to play soccer because she was from England. So I never got to play football, but everything else I played, I loved. I played a little bit too. I mean, I played everything very average at a very average rate, but I loved playing stuff, and I'm a huge sports nut. The other guy you should talk to, by the way, is Sean Hayes. He's always everybody.
We all made the same Jeff Tom. Tom Warner. Oh, yeah. He's part owner of the Red Sox and Liverpool FC, which is my club and now the Pittsburgh penguins. Fantastic. They'll come on. You guys throw these owners our way.
You know, this is a smart one thing. Yeah, for's share. Sean, what did you play? What sports did you play in school growing up? You played? Did you play soccer? I played baseball. I was on the Rens and the Roadrunners. The Rens and the Roadrunners. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And then I played football one year. Yeah. And I'd be in the, I'd be in the, I don't remember, I think I played a safety and I'd be in the Scrimmage line, right? And I'd be in the stance, you know, in all fours. And the guy across from me inevitably would always say something like, I'm going to fuck you up.
I'm going to kill you. I'm going to, like, you know, I kind of get my head. And I would take it so personally, I'd be like, I literally have done nothing to you. Why would you speak to me that way? And I used to take it so personally, I'd be like, I literally have done nothing to you. Why would you speak to me that way? And I used to take it so personally. And then I would only want to go to the McDonald's or get like the free, you know, pop or soda ever. You know what's funny about that?
You never went to McDonald's in the middle of the game, did you? You know what's crazy about that is as most of us play sports just to have fun and to do something with our friends and but there comes a point where if you're going to really play seriously, you almost have to be an asshole. And it's contrary to everything we teach our kids, raising kids to be polite, nice, respectful, help each other, all of that stuff. No, not on the basketball court. Once you get to senior at high school, maybe. But it's just different. You got to kind of be a jerk. When I played for the roadrunners,
I was auditioning for commercials too at the same time. And I get up to the plate and the coach thought he was being real supportive of like, hey, he's hit that out. I was United Airlines commercial. I auditioned for him. Hit it all the way to United Airlines. And I'm like, you, hit that out. Oh, it's United Airlines commercial. I'll just bring it all away to United Airlines. And I'm like, you don't have to do that. It's really nice, but I'm just trying to hit the ball.
It's very kind of you, but you don't have to relate the two. Hey, Rex, is there a common denominator in terms of warning signs with a new owner coming in that you got to look for? Is there other things? denominator in terms of warning signs with a new owner coming in that you got to look for. Is there other things? No, players, players normally just play. The funny thing though is that you can always tell practices are, you know, it's kind of your punching the clock, you're putting your
time in. Don't let the owner walk into practice. The owner walks into practice, everything ratchets up a notch or two notches. Everybody plays harder, wants to put on their best face for the owner. And it doesn't matter what team, what franchise, if the owner walks into practice, you know, you're gonna have a hard practice, because the coach is gonna push you harder
and the players are gonna play hard. Yeah, it's a boss. The guy who signs the check comes in. I mean, I don't care if I'm sweeping in the corner of the boss walks in, I'm sweeping that twice the pace. That's exactly right. Especially if they got a Nazi arm band on. Yeah, that's gonna make you pick up the pace of you see
if you're fucking an actual Nazi. Turbo. Jesus. That is genius. Tronati. Turbo. Jesus. That. That is genius. Rack does get your attention. Rack Chapman. It's called owned. It is fun, funny, dynamic, surprising. You're great. The guests are great.
We're so lucky to have you part of the smartness media family. Fair enough. God bless you. It's such a great show. I love it. Thanks so much for having me guys. Rex. I love you. Thank you. Love you guys. I'll see. Well, that's a man that can host a podcast clearly. Yeah. Yeah. Got a nice speaking voice. And he was a huge NBA star. And he understands the sport right from the inside. Uh-huh. Yeah. So you can, I mean, we're in good hands with him. It seems like, you know, I guess we could do. I don't know about you guys, but I never read his auto. Bye. Oh,
agafate. We'll check out on out now wherever you get your podcasts. This episode was recorded on May 25th. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondri app. Since his death in 2009, the world has struggled with how Michael Jackson should be remembered, as the King of Pop or as a monster. I'm Leon Nefak, the host of Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn.
And I'm Jay Smooth, a hip-hop journalist and cultural commentator. Michael Jackson was accused of child molestation for the first time in 1993. Our new podcast Think Twice, Michael Jackson, is the story of what came before and what came after. Throughout the podcast, we explore what makes Michael Jackson seemingly uncancellable. And we dig into the complicated feelings so many of us have when we hear Billie Jean at the grocery store. Through dozens of original interviews with people who watched the story unfold firsthand, think twice as an attempt to reconcile our conflicted emotions about Michael Jackson, the man with our deep-seated love of his art.
Listen to think twice, Michael Jackson, wherever you get your podcasts, or you can binge the entire series at free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music app. wherever you get your podcasts, or you can binge the entire series at free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.